[Music]
in 1983 David Oates dropped his Walkman
into the toilet now if you're under 40
years old a Walkman was a portable
cassette player if you're under 30 a
cassette was how we listened to music in
the Stone Age anyway after being dropped
David's tape player would only play
tapes in Reverse at first he thought
this was entertaining there are lots of
songs that contain hidden messages that
you could only hear if you played them
backward but those messages were placed
there intentionally soon David
discovered messages hidden in human
speech that were not intentional
messages that were put there by the
speaker's subconscious now turns out we
all do this in fact when we lie our
subconscious actually encodes the truth
backward inside the lies that we tell
now this is really interesting because
that means the truth about every
conspiracy is right in front of your
nose if you know how to find it
oh
when David Oates broke his cassette
player he didn't realize how far down
this Rabbit Hole went reverse recordings
have been around ever since recordings
were invented Thomas Edison liked
playing music backward on the phonograph
Infamous occultist Aleister Crowley told
his followers that they should learn to
listen to recordings and watch films in
Reverse in the 1950s Raymond Bayless and
Attila Von Soleil would play recordings
in Reverse to try to hear messages from
the dead this was actually the beginning
of EVP or electronic voice phenomena but
occultists and Ghost Hunters were Fringe
cases reverse recordings would hit the
mainstream when the Beatles started
experimenting with backward messages in
their music at the end of the song Reign
the last few seconds of the track are
backward John Lennon said this was an
accident but he liked the way it sounded
so he kept it in from then on hold on
you're not gonna play it nope copyright
right so if any of this episode has
audio muted that's because someone put
in a copyright claim now if that happens
I'll put this episode patreon but you
won't have to join to hear it it would
be nice if you became a member but you
won't have to anyway from then on if you
bought a Beatles album you had to play
it in reverse to see if there were any
hidden messages now this caused quite a
stir in 1966 after Paul McCartney was in
a bad car accident
whoa how the hell did he survive this
well that's the thing according to the
urban legend he didn't wait what well
there's a lot to the Paul is dead urban
legend I'll just hit the bullet points
but if you want a full episode on this
one email me or let me know in the
comments but the gist is this in 1966
The Beatles were the biggest rock band
in the world but in the early morning
hours of November 9th Paul McCartney was
killed in a terrible car crash no Paul
no Beatles oh no white pool why not
Ringo now come on that's not nice but
that Ringo we would have never had the
classic film caveman dude
Kaka
I stand corrected anyway to keep the
Beatles going Paul was replaced by a man
named Billy Campbell winner of a Paul
McCartney look-alike contest a contest
held for this very purpose Billy was
taught to speak with a Liverpool accent
and had to play a few chords on the
guitar now John really didn't like the
idea of replacing Paul but he went along
with it but he did start dropping hints
of Paul's death and people began to
notice the hints on the album cover of
Sergeant Pepper's the flowers above the
left-handed bass guitar spell lies and
if you hold a mirror up to the drum you
get 1 1 or 11 and 9 and he died Paul
died on November 9th now there's an open
hand above Paul's head which has been
said to be either a symbol of death or
the representation of a priest a
blessing Paul at the time of his death
on the Yellow Submarine album cover
there's a hand over Paul's head again if
we open up the album for Magical Mystery
Tour here's a hand above Paul's head and
again again and again
on the Abbey Road album cover Paul is
the only Beetle walking out of Step
symbolizing he's not one of them and the
way each of them is dressed is symbolic
John is dressed like a minister or some
say like Jesus Christ Ringo represents
the pallbearer Paul is the corpse and
George is dressed as the gravedigger and
Paul is the only man Barefoot now many
people are buried without shoes and in
the background is a white beetle with a
license plate 2 8 i f meaning at the
time this photo was taken Paul would
have been 28 if he was still alive okay
these are getting spooky but the really
creepy Clues come from the music at the
end of Strawberry Fields Forever you can
hear Jon saying very faintly I buried
Paul
but that's played forward there are a
couple of songs that give us more clues
if played in Reverse at the end of I'm
so tired you can hear nonsense but if
you play it backwards
[Music]
and at the beginning of Revolution
number nine if you play the beginning
backwards
and this kicked off Decades of musicians
putting backward messages in their songs
it really freaking me out man well if
you're scared now you're really not
gonna like what's coming
it's common knowledge that musicians
sometimes put backward messages in their
songs this is called back masking some
messages and songs are obvious
[Music]
ly
some are not so obvious
[Music]
and some are really clever
and some messages are disturbing
[Music]
backwards it says here's to my sweet
Satan before
my heart
did you hear that
[Music]
[Applause]
listen carefully it says I want to live
it backwards like the Zep whose power is
Satan
[Music]
some messages sound disturbing but
they're actually quite positive
see
[Music]
now these phrases were all placed in
music intentionally but David Oates
began listening to regular conversations
in reverse then he thought he heard
words phrases and sometimes entire
sentences encoded backward in everyday
speech now these aren't placed there
intentionally but are placed there
unintentionally by our subconscious
David first tested his theory on one of
the most famous quotes of all time
foreign
that can't be possible David Oates was
stunned also he started recording
conversations whenever he could and he
found that everyone was inserting
backward messages into their speech
about every 30 seconds or so David Oates
says that human speech has two separate
modes that serve different functions but
complement each other one mode is spoken
forward with the conscious mind the
other mode is backward speech which is
encoded by our subconscious this mode
contains emotions inner thoughts and our
true intent but as he continued his
research he learned something else
specifically when it comes to
politicians and public figures when
someone lies they subconsciously encode
the truth in their own speech now this
now becomes very interesting when you're
listening to say senior members of the
government discussing the moon landings
or JFK
telling you the moon landings are fake
the head does the backwards talking
thing finally prove it well if you
believe David oates's theory about
backward speech it does
[Music]
speed up that day when all of God's
children black men and white men Jews
and Gentiles Protestants and Catholic
will be able to join hands
the Lord
and
[Music]
I want to thank also all the people on
this campaign
now when he first discovered Neil
Armstrong's reverse speech saying mammal
spacewalk David Oates was amazed but he
didn't think much more about it he's not
a moon landing conspiracy believer but
he got so many requests from people to
dig deeper that he started analyzing as
many people connected to the Apollo
Mission as he could find the moon
landing is fake isn't it it's definitely
fake is it fake it's fake right well I
don't know if we can say without a doubt
the moon landing was fake definitely
fake but there does appear to be some
information that was covered up here's
Buzz Aldrin shut up
[Applause]
and Neil Armstrong we
took the opportunity to try to take some
some photographs of it but our film was
just not sufficiently fast to uh to
capture the event uh however this does
show the brightest part of the solar
Corona it extends the several Moon
diameters
another from Buzz uh this seemed to work
uh but without quite the same degree of
control uh of your stability as you
moved along
Buzz Aldrin again we did find that uh
Mobility on the surface was in general
uh a good bit better than perhaps we had
anticipated it then now
please
that is the U.S eagle carrying the Olive
Branch
to the lunar surface and we thought it
was appropriate to deposit this replica
of the Olive Branch before we left
uh snare for life
that lowers our altitude down to 50 000
feet we had two guidance systems working
for us and they uh behaved perfectly the
lowers are out virus
Illinois
but who's telling them to lie well
Michael Collins might have an answer
right in general just a series of slides
which in the interest of time I'm not
going to dwell on but I
this is
so we know who the Masters are I'm
assuming President Nixon also knew
credit to the control center in this
case they were the people that really
came through and helped us and said
continue which is what we wanted to hear
well there is
Neil Armstrong again turns out that
we're quite busy throughout the time
period with the the same sorts of things
that the crews of past whites have done
after their flight
powers
so if we view the moon landing with a
skeptical eye definitely fake let's
listen to Neil Armstrong again we know
he says man will space walk but some
people believe he's saying this in the
future tense meaning man will space walk
but hasn't done so yet
I have a platform
well I'll leave it up to you to decide
but before you make that decision check
out David oates's website and he has
plenty of reversals that seem to confirm
that the moon landing did happen and
look I understand that to some people
reverse speech sounds like science
fiction or at least pseudoscience and
for some it might be hard to take
seriously but there is one group that
takes reverse speech very seriously
who's it the CIA
if you follow this channel you know that
the CIA has been involved in a large
number of projects that would be
considered pseudoscience or paranormal
project Iron Eagle operation often
project Jedi these investigated the use
of psychics in intelligence gathering oh
is it really called project Jedi yep
that program was launched in the 80s
yeah we need Star Wars movies were good
project Bluebird the precursor to MK
Ultra included experiments in hypnosis
and the use of drugs to enhance psychic
abilities and project Grill flame
project center lane and the famous
project Stargate all researched remote
viewing and there are lots more programs
that we know about and plenty that we
don't so it's no surprise that the CIA
was or is looking into reverse speech
the United States government first
became interested in 1990. David Oates
had been publicly analyzing speeches
from President Bush leading up to the
Gulf War but we must recognize
that Iraq may not stop using Force to
advance its ambitions Iraq has massed an
enormous war machine on the Saudi border
Simone and the times
[Music]
now David didn't know who or what Simone
was but the word kept coming up over and
over again in Reverse speech analysis of
President Bush and other security
officials turns out a Simone is a
weather phenomenon that occurs in the
Middle East it's a hot heavy wind that
can sometimes exceed 130 degrees
Fahrenheit it's a cyclone that carries
clouds of dust and sand humans and
animals caught in a Simone often
suffocate in other words a Simone is a
Desert Storm wait when was Operation
Desert Storm 1991 the following year
reverse speech revealed clues about a
United States military operation while
it was still in the planning stages this
information was sent in a memo to Dick
Cheney and the defense department and
CNN got a hold of it may sound hard to
believe that it's creating quite a
spirit
and today the brave American and allied
forces are keeping rocks along the Sands
and off the shores of Saudi Arabia
taking a speech about the Persian Gulf
but it became the secret code word which
can only be heard by listening to the
truth backwards
foreign
[Music]
speeches about the gulf crisis
almost immediately David Oates was
invited to Washington to meet with
representatives from several
intelligence agencies he was invited uh
well he was strongly encouraged well
during a five-day Workshop a senior FBI
official said about reverse speech if
this is real there are no more secrets
and David Oates left Washington DC and
returned to his home in Dallas and
that's when strange events started
happening and he was hit with a lot of
bad luck a few days after returning home
there was a drive-by shooting at his
house the following night he received a
phone call the caller said leave JFK
alone and hung up David had published
some reverse speech analysis of Lee
Harvey Oswald that seemed to indicate he
didn't act alone and was part of a
bigger conspiracy everybody knows that
well that's not the official report oh
you believe in official government
report huh well you know what I want to
do I want to shave you down and make a
sweater out of your wool because I'm
ashamed because you're a chief that's
right
a lot of reverse speech is
interpretation but David Oates
interprets this clip of Lee Harvey
Oswald as him hinting to a conspiracy
the fact that I did uh live for a time
in Soviet Union gives me excellent
qualifications through a repudiate
charges in Cuba and the fair play for
Cuba committee is communist controls
here
is
everything
Oswald also claims the conspiracy is
being orchestrated by powerful people
and when and where because of the fact
that we certainly don't have any trade
with them we are discouraging trade uh
with that country
[Music]
exactly what people Oswald gives us a
clue well I have a study Marxist
philosophy yes sir and also other
philosophers
sometimes your reverse speech isn't
specifically connected to your forward
speech but when it is connected this is
called a congruent reversal these people
have given me a hearing without legal
representation or anything I didn't
shoot anybody
yes
another congruent reversal Oswald denies
shooting the president but in Reverse
tells us there were three Shooters
no so I don't
foreign
suggest a three-man team now the reason
Oswald was killed in custody he was
gonna talk
police officers have not allowed me to
to have any
games
here's an interesting comment by
President Johnson
America's got to be United this hour and
uh
um
President Johnson addresses Congress
we must be ready to defend the national
interest
and to negotiate the common interest
this is the path that we shall continue
to pursue
I assume that prayer for three cents
our shoe the Crafters makes sense
this is our challenge
not to hesitate
not to pause not to turn about and
linger over this evil moment
but to continue on our course
what a flat out confession from
President Johnson you got it
on the 20th day of January
in 1961
John F Kennedy told his countrymen
that our national work would not be
finished in the first thousand days
[Music]
a conspiracy like this would need the
help of the FBI so here's FBI director J
Edgar Hoover talking with LBJ
the presidential
[Applause]
election one on either side standing on
those steps of the at the back bumper
editor
[Applause]
lots of people were part of this plan
including police and we trust them to
stay quiet neither of the police
officers on either side made any
movement to push them away or to grab it
wasn't until after the gun was fired
that they then moved
that there are options
David oates's research must have upset
somebody because after publishing these
and other Clips his house burned down
oh no
we'll be home
anyway whether I'll be an asset or
liability
uh the survey show that it's helped
because I think
we need
[Music]
David Oates worked from homes when his
house burned down a lot of his research
was destroyed he was able to recover one
tape though he was recording When the
house started burning oh he was in the
house when they lit it up oh yeah this
wasn't just arson this was attempted
murder anyway on the tape you hear
someone yell to David that the house is
on fire David then runs out of the room
about 30 seconds later you can hear one
or possibly two people ransacking his
office and David could hear Whispering
on the tape David Oates moved his
operation into an office building and
strange events follow him there too his
office was broken into multiple times
and his staff discovered a program on
one of his computers every day at 3am it
was downloading all of his data and
sending it to an IP address in Virginia
as is common with whistleblowers and
other people with information the
government doesn't like David Oates was
ridiculed When government officials were
asked about reverse speech they said it
was nonsense when asked about David
Oates giving a workshop to intelligence
agencies they denied knowing anything
about it but in 2016 the CIA
Declassified David oates's file they
were keeping tabs on him and his books
they did take reverse speech seriously
they probably still do but reverse
speech doesn't have to just be about
solving conspiracies you could also use
it to solve crimes you could interview a
suspect and then play the conversation
back to find out the truth and David
Oates has helped law enforcement in
exactly this way on David's website you
can buy training materials to teach
yourself how to identify reverse speech
and David's students have used reverse
speech during employee interviews to
identify the best candidates it's been
used to successfully warn a CEO not to
sign a deal that had hidden traps
reverse speech is also used in personal
development for people struggling with
anxiety or depression reverse speech has
been used by psychologists to better
understand the subconscious it's helped
families reconnect it's given students
Clarity when faced with major life
decisions now some would argue that
people go to psychics to help them with
major decisions and that's usually a
scam but reverse speech is different
there is no Spirit talking through a
medium there are no tarot cards no
crystal ball with reverse speech you can
hear the words with your own ears and
that it's up to you to make the
interpretation now chances are you are
already leaning in One Direction you
just needed someone to give you some
advice and a little push with reverse
speech the person giving you advice is
someone that you know without question
has your best interest in mind
that person is you
yeah
well sooner or late I don't know if it's
all going to be coming out at once I
mean the one thing for sure is the thing
that's on a lot of people's minds is
what about Outdoors
we must know we must know
so reverse speech is it a real thing
well officially no reverse speech is
considered pseudoscience at least for
now it's being debated and there's a
reason for that the clips I play today
are the best ones I could find i cherry
pick them most reversals are kind of
like this the business is doing well and
we're doing well it's uh
um
are you talking about well according to
David Oates most reversals are metaphors
so when we listen to this Neil Armstrong
clip the reverse is wife feel the vomit
okay
oh yeah
David Oates interprets this that Neil
Armstrong feels like his wife is
probably very worried
how about this reversal where Armstrong
says we were wanting that knob stop it
well I'm you know I really think that
had we not done that we'd still been all
right but it was just insurance it's
nice to get a little insurance now
no
reality this was interpreted as
something on the Lander had been broken
and they needed to fix it but that's
really just an interpretation of a
metaphor which will mean different
things to different people this is often
what happens with so-called profits like
Nostradamus let's look at Century 3
quatrain 34.
everyone with differ on the
interpretation aggress unguarded none
would have foreseen it for a long time
this was interpreted as the
assassination of JFK the eclipse of the
sun is the darkening of Kennedy's
presidency the monster was Lee Harvey
Oswald and the three other Shooters
right but then after the 9 11 attacks
people said the eclipse was the collapse
of the twin towers and the monster
represents the terrorists and I can
understand either of these but I'm an
American these are two very
american-centric interpretations I bet
Asian cultures have different
interpretations Muslim cultures
definitely do what if your Ukrainian
couldn't the monster be Putin or the
Russian army and maybe the eclipse
predicts the destruction of Kiev or
Ukraine losing the war this is
reflection and projection people
naturally interpret metaphors through
the lens of their own culture their own
age group and their own language and
like Nostradamus reverse speech
interpretations will be radically
different for different people but as
you can see not only is the
interpretation completely subjective but
so are the words themselves different
people might hear different things check
out this clip of Bill Clinton David
Oates hears I like the path on my girl
bunny with the covid-19 outbreak on a
path to killing 200 000 people and
destroying millions of jobs in small
businesses
I don't hear that at all I don't
for some reason hey it makes sense with
this guy does it yeah nobody Playboy
magazine naked lady Bill Clinton loves
those fair enough so you can see why
reverse speech is controversial the
human brain really doesn't like chaos
and Randomness it likes order this is
why you see familiar shapes and clouds
grilled cheese sandwich looked like
SpongeBob riding a broomstick while
wearing a cowboy hat that's oddly
specific but that's how it works your
brain fills in as many details as it can
it's called paradolia and this could
occur with sound too it's called audio
or auditory paradolia when you hear
backward speech it sounds really random
so your brain tries to make some sense
of it this could be why reverse speech
is perceived as a string of metaphors
because how else do we connect Bob Lazar
with eloping so I mean that was the
first time I knew that this is really
something different what was it
with muscular
or afraid with muscular but there are
reversals of the Czar that do make some
sense
and you got that job before that you
were working
before that I had worked at Los Alamos
right National Labs in New Mexico
you know you can turn on electromagnet
and it makes a magnetic field we can't
make a gravitational field
you know when I worked there I was on
the front page of the the paper so they
were still able to Archive you know
break bring that back from the archives
and you know Bob Lazar a physicist
working here at Los alamoso there was at
least something there
this is if I was this is the first this
is a frog but again is there real
meaning here or is our brain trying to
help us out because some of these
reversals do make sense in certain
contexts honestly it's hard to say now
Skeptics will say there is zero to
reverse speech that the human brain just
can't process language this way well if
you're one of those Skeptics I've got
bad news for you
foreign
is an amazing machine it's fine I
wouldn't say amazing it's amazing
high-end processors on a desktop
computer run about five gigahertz so it
processes about 5 billion operations per
second that's a lot but the human brain
can process between 10 quadrillion and
100 quadrillion calculations per second
that means a human brain is between 2
million and 20 million times faster than
a high-end computer and look maybe you
can't multiply two numbers as fast as a
calculator but think of all the things
your brain does in one second it's
controlling the movements of all your
muscles it's monitoring your breathing
your heartbeat it's controlling your
internal temperature regulating blood
pressure and hormone levels it's growing
hair and nails digesting food and doing
thousands of other internal operations
in that same second your brain is
processing sensory information sights
sounds touch smell taste it's connecting
your senses with your emotions your
brain is making new memories and
deciding which ones scarred and which
ones to file away and is retrieving
memories to help you better adapt your
environment and these are all
calculations that your brain does
automatically but at the same time all
that is happening your brain can learn
to play an instrument acquire a skill
learn a language or learn to speak in
Reverse so for Skeptics to say the human
brain can't process speech backward I
give you John Austin it's the backwards
dude I'm taking my talent out on the
street here in Charlotte North Carolina
the weather is mild today yeah the Lambs
that were though with
the weather is mild today
dude
this is Sean from April 2. giving a
shout out to the wife house okay that
guy is amazing I agree now check this
out
we fit in that
Riverdale
can you guess what he's singing let's
play it in reverse
ruin all the red nose drain he had a
very shiny nose
and if you ever saw him he would even
say it close so John can reverse speak
in real time and people are rightfully
blown away by this but all he's really
doing is speaking another language
rather than learn Spanish or French John
learned reverse speak maybe not as
useful as Spanish but still impressive
so encoding thoughts backward and
forward speech that is something that
our brains can do and according to David
Oates we learned this at an early age
specifically he claims we learned
speaking backward before we learn
speaking forward
[Music]
um
oh yeah
now is this auditory paradolia are we
assigning meaning where it doesn't
belong I honestly don't know but I'm
fascinated by it and here's something
you can try record your daughter telling
you what she did on spring break or
record your husband talking about his
business trip then play those
conversations in reverse
my second thought don't do that
sometimes secrets are just better kept
the secrets but not when it comes to our
elected officials or anyone that has
power over our lives if just one person
was able to use reverse speech to figure
out what politicians are really saying
that would be like a superpower but if
an entire population can do it that
would probably lead to Anarchy so you'll
have to make a choice dishonesty from
your leaders and the status quo or
honesty and Anarchy I know what I choose
thank you so much for hanging out with
me today my name is AJ you know Heckle
fish it's your service this has been the
live files if you had fun or learned
anything do us a favor like comment
subscribe share I know it's annoying
that I asked but it really does help and
like most topics we cover on this
channel today's was recommended by you
so if there's a story you'd like to see
or learn more about go to the yfiles.com
tips and special thanks to our patrons
who make the Wi-Fi as possible you guys
are amazing and if you'd like to support
the channel or just join an incredible
Community consider becoming a member on
patreon or joining our Discord or grab
something for the Wi-Fi store yeah how
do you say buy a heck of fish mug
backwards I don't I I don't know
fish Echo yeah that's it right gum
shackle fishing I gotta work on it you
do that that's gonna do it until next
time did they see your pardon Rock
what you didn't see that coming
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]